after failing to reach a deal yesterday
lawmakers now say they're finally
closing in on a nearly two trillion
dollar emergency stimulus package
it'll help Americans and businesses
suffering from the impact of the corona
virus outbreak Nancy Cordes is on
Capitol Hill Nancy where do we stand
this morning good morning what we're
told that one extra day of talks did
yield some results more aid to state and
local governments more help for
hospitals around the country but now the
pressure is really on to seal this deal
and vote with the hopes that all this
money will help convince hard-hit
businesses to keep their workers on I
believe we are close senators promised
relief is on the way in the form of a
bill that's growing so fast no one knows
just how much it costs 1.2 1.3 trillion
roughly a two trillion dollar piece of
legislation negotiations centered Monday
night around a new 500 billion dollar
fund for loans to big industries
Democrats say there aren't enough rules
to govern who gets what arguing for
transparency and accountability on the
money that goes to any business large or
small is not unreasonable the president
only added to their fears with this
response to Paula Reid look I'll be the
oversight i'll be the republicans want
to pass the bill now they say the delay
is costing jobs right now Americans are
losing hope even as they spoke GE
announced it would lay off about 2,500
workers the massive bill would provide
up to four months of unemployment
insurance at a workers current salary
there's also 350 billion dollars in
loans for small businesses with
incentives to retain their workers all
eyes are now on Democratic leader Chuck
Schumer and Treasury secretary Steve
minuchin we met six times yesterday list
of outstanding issues has narrowed
significantly getting this bill
past is only the first challenge then
the government has to figure out how to
get all the money out the door quickly
Tony all right Nancy thank you very much